what is life
so you said there's some order
and yet there's complexity
so it's not perfectly ordered it's not
boring there's still some fun in it
and it also feels like the processes
have a direction
through the selection mechanism they
seem to be
building something always better
always improving i mean maybe it's i
mean that's a perception that's our
romanticization of things are always
better
things are getting better we'd like to
believe that i mean you think about the
world from the point of view of bacteria
and bacteria are the first things to
emerge from whatever environment they
came from
and they dominated the planet very very
quickly and they haven't really changed
four billion years later they look
exactly the same so about four billion
years ago
bacteria started to
to really run the show
and then nothing happened for a while
nothing happened for two billion years
yep then after two billion years we see
another single event origin if you like
of of our own type of cell the
eukaryotic cell so cells with a nucleus
and loss of stuff going on inside
another singular origin it only
happened once in the history of life on
earth maybe it happened multiple times
and there's no evidence everything just
disappeared but we have to at least
take it seriously
that there's
something that stops bacteria from
becoming more complex
because they didn't you know that's a
fact that they emerged
four billion years ago and something
happened two billion years ago but the
bacteria themselves didn't change they
remain bacterial so there is no
trajectory necessary trajectory towards
great complexity in human beings at the
end of it it's very easy to imagine that
without photosynthesis arising or
without eukaryotes arising that the
planet could be full of bacteria and
nothing else
we'll get to that because that's a
brilliant invention and there's a few
brilliant invention along the way but
what is life
if you were to show up on earth but to
take that time machine and you said
asking yourself the question is this is
stepping stone towards
as you step along
when you see the early bacteria
how would you know it's life
is and then this is really important
question when you go to other planets
and look for life
like what
uh what is the framework of telling the
difference between a rock
and a bacteria
i mean the question's kind of both
impossible to answer and trivial at the
same time and i don't like to answer it
because i don't think there's an answer
i think we're trying to describe one
question the process there's no answer
so there's no i mean there's lots of
at least 40 or 50 different definitions
of life out there and most of them are
well convincingly obviously bad in one
way or another um
i mean there's there's for exa i can
never remember the exact words that
people use but there's a nasa uh working
definition of life
which more or less has a system which is
capable of self-sustaining system
capable of evolution or something along
those lines
and i immediately have a problem with
the word self-sustaining because it's
sustained by the environment and
i know what they're getting at i know
what they're trying to say but but i
pick a hole in that and there's you know
there's always wags who say but you know
by that definition a rabbit is not alive
only a pair of rabbits would be alive
because a single rabbit is incapable of
copying yourself
there's all kinds of pedantic
silly but also important objections to
any hypothesis the real question is what
what is you know
we can argue all day or people do argue
all day about is is a virus alive or not
and it depends on the content but most
biologists could not agree about that so
then what about a jumping gene a retro
element or something like this even
simpler than a virus but it's capable of
converting its environment into a copy
of itself
and that's about as close this is not a
definition but this is a kind of a
description of life
is that it's it's able to
parasitize the environment and that goes
for plants as well as animals and
bacteria and viruses
um to make a relatively exact copy of
themselves informationally exact copy of
themselves by the way it doesn't really
have to be
a copy of itself right it just has to be
you have to create something
that's interesting like
the way evolution is
so it is extremely powerful process of
evolution which is basically make a copy
yourself and sometimes mess up a little
bit okay that seems to work really well
i wonder if it's possible to
mess up big time mess up big time as a
standard that's the default uh it's
called the hopeful monster and you know
this doesn't work
in principle it can actually it turns
out i would say that this is due a
re-emergence this is some amazing work
from michael levine i don't know if you
came across him but uh you if you
haven't interviewed him you should
interview him yeah for uh yeah about
yeah i'm uh
talking to him in a few days oh
fantastic
so i mentioned off yes there's two
people that anja if i may mention uh
andre kapathy is a friend who's really
admired in the ai community said you
absolutely must talk
to to michael and to nick this is so
this of course i'm a huge fan of
yourself i'm really fortunate that we
can actually make this happen anyway
well michael levin is doing amazing work
uh basically about the way in which
electrical fields control development
and he's done some work with planarian
worms so flatworms where he'll tell you
all about this so i won't say any more
than the minimum but basically you can
cut their head off and they'll redevelop
a different
a new head but the head that they
develop depends if you knock out just
one um
one one one iron pump in a membrane so
you change the electrical circuitry just
a little bit you can come up with a
completely different head it can be a
head which is similar to those that
diverged 150 million years ago or it can
be a head which no one's ever seen
before a different kind of of head um
now that is really you might say a
hopeful monster this is a kind of leap
into a different direction the only
question for natural selection is does
it work is the change itself
feasible as a single change and the
answer is yes it's just a small change
to a single gene and the second thing is
it gives rise to a completely different
morphology does it work and if it works
that can easily be
a you know
a shift it but for it to be a speciation
for it to
to continue for it to to give rise to a
different morphology over time
then it has to be perpetuated so that
shift that change in the
in in that one gene
has to work well enough that it is
selected and and it goes on and copied
enough times to where you can really
test it and so the likelihood it would
be lost but but there will be some
occasions where it survives and yes the
idea that we can have sudden fairly
abrupt changes in evolution i think is
time for a rebirth what about this idea
that
kind of trying to
mathematize a definition of life
and saying how many steps
the shortest amount of steps it takes to
build the thing almost like an
engineering view of it
i like that
um because i think that in a sense
that's not very far away from what it
what what a hypothesis needs to do to be
a testable hypothesis for the origin of
life you need to spell out here's here's
each step
and here's the experiment to do for each
step
the idea that we can do it in the lab
some people say oh we'll have you know
we'll have created life within five
years but you know ask them what they
mean by life
um
we have a planet four billion years ago
with these vent systems across the
entire surface of the planet and we have
millions of years if we wanted i have a
feeling that we're not talking about
millions of years i have a feeling we're
talking about
maybe millions of nanoseconds or
picoseconds we're talking about
chemistry which is happening quickly
but we still need to constrain those
steps but we've got a you know a planet
uh doing similar chemistry you asked
about a trajectory the trajectory is the
planetary trajectory the planet has
properties it's basically it's got a lot
of iron at the center of it it's got a
lot of electrons at the center of it is
more oxidized on the outside partly
because of the sun and partly because
the heat of volcanoes puts out oxidized
gases so
the planet is a battery it's a giant
battery um and we have a flow of
electrons going from inside to outside
in these hydrothermal vents and that's
the same topology that a cell has a cell
is basically just a micro version of the
planet um
and it's uh
there is a trajectory in all of that and
there's an inevitability that certain
types of chemical reaction are going to
be favored over others and there's an
inevitability in
in what happens in water the chemistry
that happens in water some
some will be miscible with water and
will form membranes and will form
insoluble structures and you know water
nobody really understands water very
well
um and it's uh it's another big question
for experiments on the origin of life
what do you put it in
what kind of structure do we want to
induce in this water because the last
thing is likely to be is just kind of
bulk bulk water
uh how fundamental is water to life
would you say i would say pretty
fundamental
um i wouldn't like to say it's
impossible for life to start any other
way
but
water is everywhere
water's extremely good at what it does
and carbon carbon works in water
especially well so those things and
carbon is everywhere so those things
together make me think probabilistically
if we found a thousand life forms
995 of them would be carbon-based and
living in water
now the reverse question if you found a
puddle of water elsewhere
and some carbon
no just a puddle of water
is a pot of water
a pretty damn good indication that life
has
is either exists here or
has once existed here no
so it doesn't work the other way
i think you need a living planet
you need a planet which is capable of
turning over its surface it needs to be
a planet with water
it needs to be capable of of
bringing those electrons from inside to
the outside it needs to turn over its
surface it needs to make that water work
and turn it into hydrogen so i think you
need a living planet but once you've got
the living planet i think the rest of it
uh is kind of thermodynamics all the way
so if you were to run earth over a
million times
up to this point
maybe beyond to the end let's run it to
the end
uh what is it uh how much variety is
there you kind of spoke to this
trajectory that the environment dictates
like chemically i don't know in which
other way
um spiritually
like dictates kind of the direction of
this giant machine
that seems uh
chaotic but it does seem to have order
in the steps it's taking
uh how much how often will life
how often will bacteria emerge how often
will something like humans emerge how
much variety do you think there would be
i think at the level of bacteria
not much variety i think we would get
that's how many times you say you want
to run it a million times
um i would say at least a few hundred
thousand will get bacteria again oh wow
um nice because i i think there's some
level of inevitability that a wet rocky
planet will give rise through
through the same processes
to something very close i i think this
is not something i'd have thought a few
years ago but we're working with a phd
student of mine stuart harrison he's
been thinking about the genetic code and
we've just been publishing on on that um
there are patterns that you can discern
in the code or he has discerned in the
code
that if you if you think about them in
terms of we start with co2 and hydrogen
and these are the first steps of
biochemistry you come up with a code
which is very similar to the code that
we see
so it wouldn't surprise me any longer if
we found life on mars and it had a
genetic code that was not very different
to the genetic code that we have here
without it just being transferred across
some inevitability about the whole of
the beginnings of life in my view that's
really promising because if the basic
chemistry is tightly linked to the
genetic code
that means
we can interact with other life if it
exists
potentially
that's that's really exciting if that's
if that's the case okay but then
bacteria we've got then we've got
bacteria yeah um
how easy is photosynthesis
much harder i would say
you